[Music]
what if william shakespeare had a sister
who matched his imagination his wit and
his way with words would she have gone
to school and set the stage alight in
her essay a Room of One's Own Virginia
Woolf argues that this would have been
impossible she concocts a fictional
sister who's stuck at home
snatching time to scribble a few pages
before she finds herself betrothed and
runs away while her brother finds fame
and fortune she remains abandoned and
anonymous in this thought experiment
Woolf demonstrates the tragedy of genius
restricted and looks back through time
for hints of these hidden histories she
wrote when one reads of a which being
ducked of a woman possessed by Devils of
a wise woman selling herbs or even a
very remarkable man who had a mother
then I think we're on the track of a
lost novelist a suppressed poet of some
mute and inglorious Jane Austen a Room
of One's Own considers a world denied
great works of art due to exclusion and
inequality how best can we understand
the internal experience of alienation in
both her essays and fiction Virginia
Woolf shapes the slippery nature of
subjective experience into words her
characters frequently lead inner lives
that are deeply at odds with their
external existence to help make sense of
these disparities the next time you read
Woolf
here are some aspects of her life and
work to consider
she was born at align Virginia Stephen
in 1882 to a large and wealthy family
which enabled her to pursue a life in
the arts the death of her mother in 1895
was followed by that of her half-sister
father and brother within the next 10
years these losses led to Wolf's first
depressive episode and subsequent
institutionalization as a young woman
she purchased a house in the Bloomsbury
area of London with her siblings this
brought her into contact with a circle
of creatives including Ian Forrester
Clive Bell Roger Fry and Leonard Woolf
these friends became known as the
Bloomsbury group in Virginia and Leonard
married in 1912 the members of this
group were prominent figures and
modernism a cultural movement that
sought to push the boundaries of how
reality is represented key features of
modernist writing include the use of
stream-of-consciousness interior
monologue distortions and time and
multiple or shifting perspectives these
appear in the work of Ezra Pound
Gertrude Stein James Joyce and Wolfe
herself while reading Joyce's Ulysses
Woolf began writing mrs. Dalloway like
Ulysses the text takes place over the
course of a single day and opens under
seemingly mundane circumstances mrs.
Dalloway said she would buy the flowers
herself but the novel dives deeply into
the characters traumatic pasts weaving
the inner world of numbed socialite
Clarissa Dalloway with that of the
shell-shocked veteran Septimus Warren
Smith
wolf uses interior monologue to contrast
the rich world of the mind against her
characters external existences in her
novel to the lighthouse mundane moments
like a dinner party or losing a necklace
triggers psychological revelations in
the lives of the Ramseys a fictionalized
version of Wolf's family growing up to
the lighthouse also contains one of the
most famous examples of wolf's radical
representation of time in the time
passes section 10 years are distilled
into about 20 pages here the lack of
human presence in the Ramseys beach
house allows wolf to reimagine time in
flashes and fragments of prose the house
was left the house was deserted
it was left like a shell on a sand hill
to fill with dry salt grains now that
life had left it
in her novel the waves there is little
distinction between the narratives of
the six main characters wolf experiments
with collective consciousness at times
collapsing the six voices into one
it is not one life that I look back upon
I'm not one person I am many people I do
not altogether know who I am Ginny
Susan Neville Rhoda or Louie or how to
distinguish my life from theirs in the
waves six become one but in the
gender-bending Orlando a single
character inhabits multiple identities
the protagonist is a poet who switches
between genders and lives for 300 years
with its fluid language and approach to
identity Orlando is considered a key
text in gender studies the mind can only
fly so far from the body before it
returns to the constraints of life like
many of her characters Wolf's life ended
in tragedy when she drowned herself at
the age of 59 yet she expressed hope
beyond suffering through deep thought
Wolf's characters are shown to
temporarily transcend their material
reality and in its careful consideration
of the complexity of the mind her work
charts the importance of making our
inner lives known to each other not
Afraid of Virginia Woolf then check our
book wrecks list to see which of her
masterpieces our team recommends and
thanks to our partners at audible you
can download a free audio version of any
of her books on audible.com slash Ted
Edie by doing so you'll be supporting
Ted Ed's nonprofit educational mission
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]